how how long have you been a star wars
fanatic
um
ever since it came out
ever since
1977 57 may 22nd yes
wow
well how about that for some precision
yeah
so you're always so if i threw out
something like can you name
three bounty hunters and empire strikes
back
could you do it
you're evil
i couldn't even remember edward james
almost
ig 88 boss
boba fett
but you've always been a huge fan and
like i saw all these clips of interviews
back when where you were like
i just want to be in a star wars movie
some interview or some con i want to be
in a star wars movie it's something
that's always been part of you since you
were little
yeah
and always always
always the force will the force will be
with you always always yes
and
did you audition for the mandalorian
you didn't even audition
so did
which doesn't happen very often no
no
yeah but i don't understand so is it one
day you're at starbucks
and you get a call from your agent your
agent says
i think you're gonna be in a star wars
okay well i'm gonna i'm going to give
some credit to
extraordinary women
extraordinary asian women who support
you know their sisters
um i was at a party
and uh
throwback to joy luck club um tamlin
tamita
dear friend amazing human being she knew
what a huge star wars fan i was and at
that party was debra chao
who was directing mandalorian
and she came up to me and she said you
have to meet deborah you and she knows
everybody she's like she's the social
butterfly which i'm not
like i don't even know how i succeed in
this business seriously i don't schmooze
i don't because you're charming and you
don't know anyone
no you're
you are one of the most charming people
i have ever encountered
you light up a room immediately light up
a room i'm not just saying that when you
are in a room everybody gravitates
towards you you have that it that's what
it is
but go ahead go ahead please so she
introduced you so she introduced me to
deborah debra and i just started talking
and we hit it off and you know and then
she's like oh you know what
i'm gonna i'm gonna you know mention you
two you know how people say that and
you'd never happen it never happens
and sure enough yeah that's do you
remember the day do you remember the
moment where were you when you got the
call
oh wow
that's a good i don't remember what
happened yesterday no um
i remember
getting um
not a call like it's so weird our
managers and our agents like they just
email stuff but i think they did call me
that day
and
i read the script
and at first i was a little
sad and concerned because you know
fennec shan dies
in the script yes in the script and i
was like gosh i've been holding off for
so long you know what is it like
40 years but hang on hang on your first
reaction should have been like yes yes
oh yeah totally totally my first
reaction i was like oh my gosh oh my
gosh and i'm reading it i'm reading and
i'm like oh yes yes yes she's an
assassin
and she gets shot in the gut and dies
it's like
oh
it just like broke my heart so totally
so what did you do you went to set and
were you did you did you mention it like
do i have to die did you talk to anybody
no no what happened was like you know i
had a a lengthy conversation with john
favreau and dave filoni two of the most
and again they're they're in the caliber
of george flooney for me
the nicest human beings you know the
kindest creative
just
saints really
um so i
i had a long conversation with them and
just loved
the take that you know they were going
with it and so i go on set i'm like you
know what this might be my only
opportunity i i gotta do it right
so yeah i did
and i go on set and the costume was
amazing and you know i worked on the
hair idea with maria and we were like
really being creative about this
character because i'm like okay if it's
only going to be one episode
i'm going to make her like stand out you
know i'm going to have this like really
cool hairdo to go it's really like i i
really invested a lot into it right and
i was so excited and and um the first
time like i was on the volume
not realizing what it was
and and i got on set and literally there
was like one rock and some sand
and i was just like
wow this is like you know
it's like that's it back in the day the
black box theater
but you
yeah
99 cedar where you had a one-man show
turns into a table that turns into a
chair that turns into your house you
know
there was just nothing there but there
you of course there's gonna be a world
in post
well i didn't know you know i was just
like wow okay not very impressive
did you say anything to anybody like is
this what is this
these are my inner nerd thoughts
and then they light it up and it was
this inc it was tatooine
with the binary sunset and i freaked i
mean literally i teared up i teared up
so much i was so overwhelmed with
emotions
and then i for asked the first lady kim
richards who was this incredible human
being i'm like okay i know we're not
supposed to take pictures and said but
you have to you have to take this
picture of me looking at the binary
sunset with my one foot up like luke
skywalker